Hello.
Welcome to our first workshop.
This is the complete guide to InfluxDB two.
Today's workshop, we're going to be exploring one
of the more challenging
parts of InfluxDB two for people that are
just not familiar
with creating with flux.
There are a few
challenges
and quirks
to this brand new equality language that you
only learn through guided tuition or
plenty of head banging against the wall.
So I'm glad you've chosen this approach.
Now, this is a
workshop. This is the first time that we've
done that in this course.
And the format will be,
there is a
README file
on GitHub
where you can read through
all the materials
and do the exercises.
What I'm gonna do today is read through
all the materials and do the exercises.
Now I'll give you plenty of warning before
I move on to the exercises, so I
would encourage you to follow along with me
as we go through the materials
and then
don't watch the exercises.
If you're watching live,
well, you know,
yes, please watch the exercises.
But if you're not watching live, pause it.
Use that as an opportunity to go and
test your own logic. Anyone who joins me
live today, we will try and make this
a little bit more interactive than previous sessions
via the tutorials and the lectures,
but we want this to be fun. So
we have our screen shared here.
You can find the resources for this course
at github dot com slash rockode academy.
I have started adding the materials to the
courses repository.
There is a InfluxDB complete guide,
and we are starting on part five today,
an introduction to Flux, the workshop.
Excuse me.
Now,
this course is a living course. This course
will be continuing to update week after week
and
possibly in the future as new features and
things come and change within InfluxDB too.
So I can't exactly go back and modify
a livestream,
so you may see a little bit of
variation and change from what is in the
readme during today's session, but I will do
my best to follow-up with more workshops as
required as the material evolves over time.
Okay.
Let's see. So
in order to dive into Flux today, we
do need to start collecting some
Oh, that's annoying. Well, let's get rid of
that.
Got to notice that early.
This is the watermark. That's what it is.
Okay. So in order to
explore Flux today,
we need some data.
So we're going to get InfluxDB to running
on my machine.
We're going to run with this configuration
from Telegraph.
I'll copy that. We will jump over here
and
we'll paste it in.
As the instructions note, you will need InfluxDB
to be running
an organization called Rawkode Academy with a bucket
called workshop. So I will
do that now also, and I'll just make
sure that I don't have any preexisting
data.
So we run InfluxDB,
and I'll get another
terminal here.
And we'll just give that a few seconds
to run.
I haven't worked out why it takes so
long on my Mac, but it just seems
to be on my Mac. And I'm assuming
it's because I'm on the latest beta
of Mac OS Monterey.
So
maybe something weird going on here.
Perfect.
And nice coffee.
Okay.
So let's get our InfluxDB cooking.
Loco Jose.
Close, but no cigar.
Loco https.
There we go.
So we're gonna click get started. My username,
I'll pick a password.
We want our organization
to be Rawkode Academy
and our bucket to
be workshop.
Zooming in on Influx UI is really difficult.
So
maybe we just have to try and make
do with this.
I'm gonna click configure later.
We'll go to data and tokens and we
get an admin token created for us, which
I will copy.
And we will export this as Influx
token.
We can then run telegraph
like so.
All right, let's close that.
And that's all these instructions here are also
saying. So we created our organisation,
we named our bucket workshop
and we exported our Influx token environment variable,
and this config will just work for you.
The configuration of Telegraph that we're using here
is just configured with a
high resolution or short
two second interval
so that we are collecting metrics every two
seconds. We wanna see data pretty fast here
today.
And we've got a flush interval of six
seconds. That just means that Telegraph will collect
metrics every two seconds. It will hold them
in memory, and every six seconds, it will
write them to the database.
Really, our flush interval would be higher in
normal circumstances, and we leverage batching and buffering
much more. However, we do want a pretty
quick feedback cycle as we query and work
with Flux today.
Now we are configuring Telegraph with the CPU
plugging, although I have disabled the total CPU
metric
just to force us to do that through
aggregation functions within Flux. And we'll talk about
that as we move through today's workshop.
I've then got it configured with all the
other system metrics. So we'll be looking at
this, this IO, memory, net, processing swap, and
system.
These are pretty much all the plugins that
work across all operating systems don't really require
any configuration and get you data pretty fast
that is variable and changes.
Again, important for what we're working on today
with this workshop.
Okay. So now we are going to write
our first Flux
query.
And
the markdown here will be great and it
is public, anyone can look at it, but
only Rawkode Academy members will get to see
this course and my wonderful added commentary and
flavor. So while there are things on well,
there's
little snippets of information in this markdown file,
I'm gonna be adding on a little bit
more and showing you some tips and tricks
from my usage of InfluxDB over the years.
Okay.
So there are two functions that are always
required before the flux engine will execute any
query against InfluxDB.
Excuse me.
Excuse me. Now,
you need a data source. You have to
tell it where to read the data from.
And secondly, you need a time window.
We'll see this as
from and range statements.
And there are multiple ways to actually execute
a query against InfluxDB.
So the first one is we can come
here to the explorer view where
we get this nice user interface,
where we select the bucket,
we can select the metric that we want,
we can select the fields that we care
about,
and we click submit.
And you'll see in the last five minutes,
we've got some data coming through.
This UI is great for exploring
when you're not really sure what you want
to be querying quite yet,
but it's quite restrictive if you wanna do
anything a bit more advanced or complicated.
Now you can switch from filters to grips
and begin to grip by, you know, the
values that are available.
But really,
what we want to do for the majority
of the time is to use the query
builder. So we click on query builder and
we can actually see the flux code itself.
So
another,
the
first step here then would be
use the query builder
whenever possible to at least bootstrap and start
your query.
It's a really great way to get that
from range and any filters
through a very visual means.
And then from here, can start to change
all of the query yourself.
We're not gonna use this because we're gonna
stick to what is available in the workshop.
And I'll also show you one more thing
in just a moment. So let's copy our
from statement. Okay. We'll just copy both of
these and then I'll I'll read over the
text.
There we go.
So,
what I've done here,
and then you'll see that it took a
little bit longer,
is that we have a from and a
range with no predicates, no filters, no nothing,
and it does return quite a lot of
data. And it's hard to tell, but there
is a probably a fair bit. If we
click on this view raw data tab here,
which is one of the most important tabs,
as you start to explore your data,
you'll see, yeah, I've got
a fair bit of information here.
Okay, so what's this data source? The from
function is how we select where to load
the data from. When you're creating against InfluxDB
two,
you can use from with a bucket name
and this will fetch data from that bucket.
Buckets have retention policies.
They're a very good way to
determine how long your data should live and
use them as a cascading strategy for your
data. We're gonna be talking about, done something
on Thursday,
where we will look at buckets and retention
periods in more detail,
but not today.
The other thing
that's worth noting here is that Flux,
well as embedded in InfluxDB two has always
been built with the intention of creating multiple
data sources.
So there are other functions besides from to
read from SQL compatible stores,
CSV,
HTTP endpoints and others,
but we'll only be working on InfluxDB two
for this function.
Next, we have to use a range statement.
An arranged statement has
accompanied with this little pipe forward operator, and
I've kind of done my best to explain
this here as well.
So
if you've written any Alexa or F sharp,
the pipe forward operator should be something you're
familiar with.
All it means is that we take
the output
from the first function
and we pass it as an input to
the second function.
So this from selects all data from that
bucket.
We then pass it into this, and this
is a range which will actually
filter the data to just the bits that
we need, which is the last fifteen minutes.
Okay.
So you always need a from and you
always need a range.
Alright. Something else that's cool about Flux, and
you've already seen that with our first query,
is that it has a concept of a
duration literal,
which just means that durations and times
are first class citizens.
You'll see here, we do a dash minus
15 ms to see if I need data
from now minus 15.
We have seconds available to us.
We have hours, we have days,
that's supposed to be weeks. I'll fix that.
So that's a W.
We have months,
then I see by MO,
and we have access to years.
So, you know, pretty flexible.
And there are sub seconds duration that rolls
too, you can do milliseconds and nanoseconds.
Time literals
work in multiple ways. You can use a
no function to get back to the current
time.
You can use just the year, month and
day, or you can use a fill ISO
8,601
time like so.
Now,
something that is implicit in the query that
we have used so far, is there was
no yield here.
And InfluxDB actually adds this yield to your
query automatically for you.
So you can always imagine that it's there
if you omit it. And when you do
more powerful queries across multiple datasets and you're
yielding multiple results, the yield will become much
more useful.
This will be something we look at throughout
the course, especially as we move into
monitoring real production systems.
So yield, you can omit, but you can
also name it as we do here. So
you'll see that we have a couple of
queries here. The first one is a from
range of fifteen minutes. We have a filter,
which we haven't really talked about yet, but
will be something that we talk about in
your course.
And then we yield that as that dataset
as CPU.
And then we do the same here, yielding
as memory of a different filter.
And we should be able to
What did I get wrong with Oh, I
forgot that. Is it V yield?
Here's another tip.
You can,
when you're using the UI,
you will get this list of functions on
the right hand side. This is invaluable, right?
You're never gonna remember the syntax for all
of them, just as I have forgotten.
You can type the name of the function
you need and literally just click inject.
And you'll see here, I just forgot the
name parameter. So that's a really good point.
All functions and flux take named parameters.
You'll see that with the range has a
parameter called start. It also has a parameter
called stop.
We could say,
give me
Last, well, give me ten minutes of data
starting fifteen minutes ago, like so. The filter
function
takes a function called fn, the property is
called fn, then it takes an anonymous function
inside. The yield takes a parameter called name.
So all
all functions in Flux take named parameters.
And
let's see,
we just maybe just look at this as
raw data,
We can see this is the CPU results.
And if we scroll down,
oops, still CPU. There'll be, where does this
memory start?
Oh, there we go.
Available up.
Where
are you?
Try and drag back up. It was a
bit finicky.
There's UC system at the end of CPU.
Too much data.
There we go. And there's our memory results
right here. You can see that's an active
channel. So, you can yield multiple things.
Really cool if you want to graph things
and build correlations and be able to look
at how your CPU
is affected with your memory. Like, is there
a correlation that as memory consumption goes up
or CPU issues going up, etcetera? Now, that's
a contrast example.
Your infrastructure, your applications, you'll know what you're
looking for and what you're trying to correlate.
Okay. So
that is our very first Flux query.
We've taken a look at from and range
and yield.
Those are just the things that are required
for everything you do. Filter is equally important,
but we're gonna talk about that in just
a moment.
I'm gonna run through the exercises
now. So
if you want to do the exercises on
your own time,
you want to do them now, or you
want to try them before I run through
them, now is the time to pause your
video and come back later.
I'll cut to 10 in my head while
staring intensely.
I stopped counting, I don't know when it
turns out.
Right, I'll do it. Okay, so the exercises
are nice and simple. We're gonna layer these
up week after week and add a more
complex examples,
but really we just wanna get you familiar
with entering the query into the UI, and
then we'll take a look at the Flux
CLI REPL as well. So
we want to fetch all metrics over the
last five minutes.
So we can say from
bucket
and InfluxDB
UI does use
language server protocol and Monaco with the Versus
Code Editor. So you will get relatively good
autocomplete.
Workshop
range
star dash five ms.
That's exercise one, really simple. In fact, we
already had a
variation of this right at the start as
we were copying and pasting.
So
really, you just wanna be familiar
with the pipe operator,
know that it's two characters instead of just
one that you may be familiar with from,
you know, shells,
you know, with bash scripting, you know. So
we do have the
the greater than same.
And it's important to remember, and hopefully you
get comfortable with the named parameters.
A lot of people trip up with that.
And then the duration laterals,
and what a lot of people do at
the start as they're writing their first tax
queries,
would be to forget the minus
and just
remember that you need to as a duration.
Right? So you have to go back five
minutes to get the actual time that you
want to query.
So we'll take a look at one more
thing from here.
I just opened a new tab.
And if we run Influx,
we can see there are a bunch of
Oh, what is going on with this terminal?
I've had problems with iTerm for a while
now, to be fair.
Okay.
So, we can execute flux queries
on the command line.
Guess all of my influx commands are gonna
be acting a little bit funny.
Alright. Why don't I open a new tab?
Let's just take a look at the help
on this.
So we can pass in a query that
we wish to run.
So we could say from
bucket
workshop
range
start
five ms.
Oh, and yeah, we will need a few
extra parameters as well. So when we do
this on the command line, we will need
to provide
our --org,
which is Rawkode
Academy.
And we need to export our token again.
And it should still be in my history.
That's a very old token then apparently. Let's
grab it from,
yeah, let's grab it from here again.
Export
info token.
Not the same.
Oh, wait. It's invalid expression.
Completion field, not authorization.
From
I can't remember actually if Flux cares about
the quote.
Let's do this.
From
bucket, pipe forward, range star,
go.
Oh, and fix the end one. There we
So quite a lot of data there.
Yeah. An awful lot of data.
And
have to remove the Rackle.
Oh, that's a shame.
Oh, well, you could compile
Flux from
source and there is a REPL
that I think has been removed from the
InfluxDLA.
That's unfortunate. We won't be using that today.
This one is definitely broken.
That one's definitely broken.
Those two are happy. Alright, perfect.
So
we've seen the CLI.
We've seen the UI
one more,
and there is a Versus Code extension.
So, if we jump over here,
there's your flux.
You'll see that there is this
Versus code extension from InfluxData.
You can add connections,
local
HTTP
local host.
I've got my token
and my organization
name.
And you can see we get a success
down here when we test that connection.
So let's save this.
And that means that you can
run
flux
scripts.
So we can say run query.
We need a flux fail. Right.
Query Flux
from,
and we get awesome all complete from the
IDE.
Again, using the language server, which the team
have been working on.
Academy
range
star dash five m.
Yeah. Let's just run that.
Rawkode
Academy. Oh, workshop.
Work
show the organization
as the academy.
So we can run this query.
I think it's just loading all the data.
And there.
Really, I should have narrowed down that query
before running.
Alright. Let's do that. Let's just grab
ten seconds.
There we go.
And now we can query and look at
this data in our Versus Code. So it's
entirely up to you. It's still quite a
lot of data for ten seconds. Maybe I've
got my enter full too quick.
So it's up to you. I like
using
this for the auto complete
and functional complete and help text and other
stuff,
but the web UI has also equally as
good.
And then the CLI is there if you
wanna be able to automate or build scripts
or into any of this stuff as well.
Okay.
So that was exercise 1.1.
Now we want to fetch all metrics for
the last hour,
excluding the last five minutes.
So really, we're just coming back here in
one hour, only we're adding a stop
because we don't want the last five minutes
of data.
That's gonna be a large query as well,
but the UI should be able to handle
it. He says,
hopefully.
And then the last one
is we want to fetch all metrics
for the last three hours returned as multiple
datasets.
How are they?
Yeah, there we go. And
there's just one thing I really want you
to take away from this last
task
is that we want all metrics for the
last three hours
hourly. So what does that mean? Well,
we could do
three hours
dash two hours
and just copy and paste that where we
moved down to two hours and one hour,
and we moved down to one hour
without a stop.
And we can yield each of these.
Name,
one hour,
and we'll call this two hour
and three hour.
And that will work fine.
And something else you can actually do is
assign the output
and then reuse it.
It's not very useful in this case because
it's just a from statement. This time being
reused across multiple
ranges.
But as your queries become more sophisticated and
you're doing a lot more, you may have
a set of from range and filters that
you want to be able to reuse across
multiple yields
within a single Flux script, and that is
entirely possible.
And
we'll take a look at just how that
works next, because we're about to take a
look at
filtering windows and aggregations.
Cool.
Okay. So hopefully,
you know, that first thirty minutes
of this workshop
just gets you acquainted with right in flux.
The different interfaces that you can use for
submitting your queries and working with the data.
The UI is a great place to start.
Everyone should start there first
and then move in to
the CLI Versus Code, whatever, as you need.
The Versus Code option becomes much more appealing
as we start to play with Packager, which
is a manifest format for applying InfluxDB configurations
to InfluxDB.
Kinda like KubeControl
where, you know, YAML manifests, we can do
all of that within InfluxDB to manage everything
from a GitHub pattern.
So it's actually quite nice to be able
to work with that in Versus Code and
have all your queries saved on local Flux
scripts. So and we'll be doing more in
there. Okay.
So all of our creating has been extremely
superficial thus far, and that's because we aren't
doing anything useful. We're just pulling out raw
data and actually seeing that with the, you
know, thirty minutes of data that we're already
collecting and ranging over even a few minutes
of that can be quite intensive.
And it's just because we're collecting
relatively
a lot of metrics for this little MacBook
to handle. So we wanna be able to
make sure that we are using filtering and
using filtering effectively and efficiently when we query
InfluxDB,
the leveraging things that well, the actual tensor
did risk itself to help us with the
felt string so we don't have to do
all memory. And we talk about that in
this next this next section.
Alrighty.
So
what's important here
would be
this, right? So I'll read this verbatim and
talk about it.
The filter function can filter data on any
field and a dataset.
This means that you need to be particularly
careful when adding filters and assure that you
understand when filtering on a tag or a
field.
If you think back to the lecture we
had at the start of this course, lecture
one, an introduction to time series,
I talked about how tags are indexed within
the time series database and fields are not.
Now because fields are not indexed, if we
used a filter function to filter on a
field,
what actually happens is all of that is
loaded into memory and essentially looked over and
filtered as required.
However,
if we use filters against the tag values,
which are indexed in the time series database,
we can actually just
push most of that down to the TSDB
and say, don't give me this data or
only give me this data,
We're substantially
more efficient on memory and faster on CPU.
So make sure that you're constructing your queries
appropriately.
The filter function,
and we'll do this by here. The filter
function takes a parameter called FN.
FN is not a keyword. A lot of
people make this mistake when they first start
adopting Flux. Fn is just the named parameter
and it takes an anonymous function and that
anonymous function should
return a billion or must return
a billion value of true or false. If
it returns true, the data will be kept
in the dataset and if it's returned false,
the data will be omitted.
Now you've already seen me do this now,
but using the show data toggle is the
fastest way to really understand your data as
you start creating an Influx.
So,
we can,
we don't need that right now.
Definitely don't want an error.
Well, there isn't an error, but
let's just get a little bit of data.
We can remove the yield and use the
implicit.
And
I won't be able to choose that to
a minute. So you can kind of see
this Oh, no, you can't because of my
face.
There's
a little tiny bit of data here.
So
and that's just because we're trying to show,
you know, we've got that set to five
minutes, but we're only pulling back one minute.
There's not a lot of information here. Right?
Like, if I wanted to start filtering on
my data that lives in the workshop bucket,
I don't really know how to do that
without having substantial knowledge into how it works.
So you can use the show raw data
button,
and we'll kind of talk about how this
how to navigate this big blob of text
here. I'll bring my face back in, but
if it gets in the way, I'll
remove it.
So this raw data view that we have
in the UI is a annotated CSV
almost.
Now, what we have here is that
information on the data types for each of
the columns in CSV,
and we have some group key information, which
we'll be talking about as we talk about
groups moving forward.
We
have a result,
which is our
data.
We have tables.
We have value.
We have the start and stop period.
So this will tell us about a range
within the query. We have the time that
this point value was stored.
Now, all of this is stored in a
columnar fashion
and the TSDB,
which means all of the fields that we
store, we can actually, we'll need to pivot
them to see them as robust data. Again,
stuff we'll cover in subsequent videos, don't worry
about it if you don't understand what I
mean by pivot the data.
But because this is columnar, we have a
fields code underscore field, which has a value,
which tells us which field
we're creating against.
And we'll take a look at that as
we start to build up some of these
filter queries as well.
Fields belong to measurements. So this is our
CPU measurement, will also be a memory one,
a system one, a processes one, etcetera, down
here. And then we have some tags.
So this is a CPU zero that tells
us, you know, this is a 16 core
machines. We're gonna have CPU zero to 15,
and then the host of the data was
collected.
And this is just based on what telegraph
rates to our time series database.
But using the show raw data toggle is
the best way to understand how to build
and construct your query.
Unless you want to use a query builder,
of course, you can do that too.
But what I would see here
is that I could filter on measurement equals
CPU and field equals usage guessed
to really quickly break down the status of
just one or two things that I wanna
see.
So let's copy
this query
here.
So this is a from bucket workshop, range
of fifteen minutes, and we only care about
the CPU measurement.
That means we're saying goodbye
to
disk,
disk IO, memory, network,
processing system and swap. There we go. That
was a quick tour.
We run this.
And I know fifteen minutes seems seems
like a short window, but with that two
second resolution,
that has actually quite a lot of points.
So we're getting 30 points per minute times
across 16 cores.
Very quickly adds up. And you can see
just by scrolling on this, you know, we're
we've got at least a few hundred
tables going on there. So,
yeah, that's these filters.
Now,
you can add
many of these filters
as you like.
We don't wanna fill our measurement again. Let's
say we just want a single field.
We can do usage
guest.
That should be a pretty quick query.
And now we only get a single field
for each CPU. So we're still got the
16 CPUs, but the field for each.
I
think what
is important to take away from filtering
is that the database will work out optimization
to make that as fast as possible.
As long as
you keep all of your filters together
wherever possible. Of course, you're always gonna need
filters further down the stack and that's okay.
But anything that can you wanna reduce as
much of your dataset as possible
right after the range
because that as long as you're again, as
long as you're using tags, we'll push it
all down to the time series database.
So you don't need to load all of
that into memory. And that's just as good
increase your performance substantially.
If
we were to
call another function here, and I know you
don't know what window is yet, but that's
alright.
Those filters being broken up can no longer
be optimized because we have some logic that
has to happen in between, meaning the only
filter that will get pushed down to the
time series database is a measurement. We load
everything into memory to perform the window.
And then even if this is a tag,
it doesn't matter. We're still filtering it and
memory.
So really important to understand
and try to remember that if you can
keep your filters to the start, you're gonna
have a much better performing database.
Okay.
Now,
it's really your own personal preference now, whether
how you structure your filters.
And what a lot of people like to
do is use the android and
you can say usage.
K.
And do that as a single filter. You
can have them all as individual filters.
It does not matter. Personal preference, use whatever
you like. Me,
I kind of prefer
separate filter lines as much as possible
because I think it's a little bit cleaner.
Of course, if we get down to a
certain point here where I have others and
I have to do
a slightly later filter,
then in order to avoid looking over the
data twice, although there still are performance things
that happens with the runtime that we'll try
to avoid that. And I will use the
and syntax.
But as I said, for the first bunch
of filters, I do like to to put
them together. This is one filter in the
runtime, not two.
In fact,
that's also arbitrary. I could have as many
filters like this. These would all be filtered
at once and pushed down to the time
series database as long as their tags. And
that is always, always the caveat with querying
and FluxDB too. Stick to tags as much
as possible, push the field filtering
as late in the call or the script
as possible.
Okay.
Let's talk about these results that we've been
getting.
And to do that, we have to explain
tables and grouping. So
Flux returns all data from your queries as
a set of tables, which are grouped by
a group key.
This group key by default is each series
within your data where a series is a
unique combination of tag and values.
Definitely make sure you've checked out the first
lecture, an introduction to time series. I talk
about series, tags and keys.
But let's
take a visual representation
of this. I'm gonna remove this.
We will pull out six seconds of CPU.
Woah, what did do?
Okay. Thirty seconds.
Okay. Think that the six seconds work and
I just
Oh no, because my flush interval is six
seconds. There we go. Yeah. Okay. So, view
raw data. Okay. So,
we have got a from a range and
a filter, right? These are the basic constructs
of all flux queries.
You'll see that we have table zero,
we have table one,
we have table two, we have table three,
so forth,
all the way down the stack.
So a table is a series based on
the default group key.
The group key that's been used here
is
our field name of usage guest,
the measurement of CPU,
the CPU tag,
which is, you know, each CPU will become
its own series
and the host.
So what we have here is a set
of tables for every CPU core
on this machine and
for each
field
available in the dataset,
which I think is
anywhere from eight to nine, not entirely sure,
but let's try and make this more visual.
So if we add in a new filter,
and we do field
equals and we drop this down to one
field,
we should see one series
for each variation of the series,
which now because of we have constrained the
field to a single one will be the
CPU's,
meaning we should see 16
tables.
Okay. Table zero,
table
for fifteen, sixteen tables.
Tables are the thing that trip everybody up
at the start.
Trying to get the data out because it's
columnar and and, you know, not a lot
of people are familiar with creating against columnar
databases. It's really fast on the read path
and the write path, but
comes with a little bit of a cognitive
overload that people just aren't familiar with.
So,
I hope you understand tables. If not,
leave comments on the video, jump into the
Discord,
happy to spend more time on it. And
we'll be looking at it in a little
bit more detail as we run through this
too. But really, hopefully you have a good
grasp of it already.
Okay.
And we'll copy that just so I can
make sure that the query Oh, there's a
nice little copy button. I'm
not gonna do five minutes.
Let's just do thirty seconds.
There we go.
Now,
I think I ask a question here. Yeah,
I do.
So looking at this query,
how many tables do you expect this to
return?
Okay. So from and range,
we filter on the measurement
and we are requesting
three different fields.
I'll give you a moment
or you could pause it.
And the answer is here. In fact, I
wouldn't even read the answer.
Feel free to peruse that at your own
time, but hopefully you got it right.
Okay, so now we can change the group
key to get the data in a format
that we need. Again, once you have an
understanding of what values you wanna get from
your metric data,
alright, and your event data, you can start
to piece together your queries and you'll have
a better understanding of the group key that
you need.
So let's assume that we want data above
the group by metric, ignoring the different CPUs
altogether.
So, I don't want a table
for each CPU. What I want to know
is can I have an arbitrary number that
tells me of whether my CPU is saturated
or not?
So, we do a from range, we filter
on the measurement,
and then we filter on the three fields
that we want, usage system,
usage user, and usage guest.
Now we're introducing the group function where we
can provide the number of columns to use,
or which columns to use as a group
key.
Here, the measurement is actually superficial because we're
grouping on the field.
If we had multiple measurements with a field
name that
duplicated across them all, you would want to
make sure that you restrict it properly
and you don't have like a
response
time and multiple measurements
all get grouped together because it would skew
the values. But it's usually best to be
as constrained as possible.
So measurement
field and then the motor bag.
And then if we run this,
we'll see that we get all of the
CPU numbers.
And the same table.
Perfect.
And we'll have three tables.
You can see the two on the left
here, and that is for each of the
fields.
So now we have a table for each
field that we care about, and we can
actually do aggregations
across the values, across the CPUs
to understand
whether the system is under load or not.
Alright.
How many tables do you think we'll get
back now? I just answered that. Sorry. Spoiler.
Something else I like to share with people
because, again,
it's one of those first questions I get
all the time about Flux is, but what
if I don't want a group? What if
I I just want a single table?
And you can do that through an empty
group. I tend to call it a flatten,
flatten the data, single group.
I think that's just a term that maybe
I use. Haven't heard a lot of other
people use it, but
it's just basically no group. We want to
remove the group key.
So
if we jump in here,
we can call an empty group
like so.
And now the zeros
all the way down. That just gives us
one flat table.
And the the use case for that is
just having a a single series for graphing
or pulling out explicit values
and from a bunch of aggregations that you're
making across your data.
All right, let's
try and get through this last bit within
the hour.
And I'll be back on the next video
will drop in just a couple of days.
Okay, so windows and aggregations.
There's a little note here, I just want
people to be wary of is that MO
and Y behave slightly differently
when they're used in window operations than regards
to the from. So if you use one
month for one year and a from, it
will go back thirty one days or three
sixty five days.
However, in a window operation,
they are calendar aligned.
So if you see window that's data
by month, you will get the 1 the
month to the end of the month.
And the same for years, you will get
from January 1 to December 31.
So just keep that in mind. I think
that's intuitive, what people would expect.
However,
it doesn't have to reiterate
that, of course.
So what window functions allow us to do
are to divide the data that we're creating
into windows that we wanna build aggregations for.
So let's, as an example,
we are collecting our CPU data every
two seconds. That is quite high resolution for
CPU on a standard Linux machine. As you
can see by some of the queries have
already tickled the box a little bit.
So we probably don't want to understand the
load at two second intervals because
you know, there are gonna be bursts in
CPUs as applications are spinning up and down.
It send instructions to the CPU that cause
that number to artificially
Not artificially. It goes up, but it's just
not that important because it drops back down
very quickly.
So we It's very common with time series
data to say, okay, I have two second
resolution, but I actually wanna build an aggregation,
a one minute, five minute, and fifteen minute
intervals.
Hey, you may be familiar with that already,
right? Linux load averages.
So
here's a pop quiz. I'm about to run
this query. How many tables will it return?
So this does a filter
and a filter.
So we've got a single measurement, a single
field,
and we're windowing.
And we know that I have 16 CPUs
on my machine.
So keep that in mind, have a guess,
pause it if you wanna work it out
for a minute. I am gonna go run
this query.
So fifteen minutes of CPU data, windowed every
one minute.
I'm gonna window it. Oh, in fact, yeah,
I should run it as one because that's
what I said. Right?
Two
fifty six tables.
Is that what you got?
Okay.
If you want that explained, the answer is
here. So
depends on how many CPU's you have on
your system. My machine has 16 CPUs, so
it returns two fifty six tables.
Why?
Well, we have requested a single metric and
we have 16 CPUs,
so you may have guessed it, 16 tables
would be returned.
However, because we're modifying
the group key with our new window,
and that's important to remember, windowing data does
modify the group key.
What we're actually saying is that we want
one minute intervals.
And because our range
is 15,
we are actually multiplying the number of tables
by 16.
The reason why is that we get our
fifteen minute one minute
intervals,
plus the current interval
depending on how far into that we are.
So we can actually just take a look.
So let's try and start at the top.
You can see the windows on the start
and the stop.
So we have fourteen thirty five to fourteen
thirty six, and you see that is not
a complete minute because we are halfway through
this interval
approaching this.
Whereas the other intervals
are complete, fourteen forty four to fourteen forty
five.
So hopefully that makes sense. Window changes the
group key. We are building artificial series based
because we're seeing chop this data up. Right?
So we're getting unique series because we're bringing
a time into dimension of the window.
Something that's usually quite cool about doing that
though
is the colors.
So
let's take off the window
because I wanna show you this. This is
cool.
What we see here is consistent
colors for each series within data.
So each CPU core here gets its own
color as we can see in the
the legend.
So CPU zero, it's a very light blue,
CPU nine is very orange, and then we've
got this
cascading color changes through.
And that consistent is
the color the series color is consistent across
the x axis. Now,
when we window the data,
we are having a unique series for each
window within the data.
So actually, the colors now change
along
the x axis.
You can actually see that our first series
is this time window here.
Our second series is this time window here.
Our third series is this one here. Our
fourth series is here and so forth, all
the way across there.
I always like the colors when you do
that. Very cool.
Okay. Now we have bundled data,
which is great. We have
colors, but we actually need to do some
more. We wanna be able to aggregate that.
Right? We we have 16 values across each
one minute interval and we wanna under we
want one single value across each of those
intervals to understand the CPU total load, not
per CPU.
So, one of the things we could do
is use the aggregate functions.
The one we're using here is called the
mean.
So, we want to calculate the mean across
this window.
I'll remove that. So this is the same
query as before.
CPU filter,
usage user filter, window by one minute. In
fact, if I remove this,
I think it's just a range change, but
it's still the same data.
We can
I should think,
yeah, I'll spend some time? You're probably wondering
why all my data shows on the right
here. And it's just because I'm using a
fixed range here.
If we use the variables, time range start,
we'll use the whole thing
and then we control it through this here.
I should have explained that earlier.
I just tend to use dash minus five
ms so that I Because it's easier in
the markdown than saying click on this. So
there you go.
Now we can bring in the mean.
And if we view the raw data,
we're gonna get a single value
for each
series,
which can't be graphed because a single value
for each series is a point.
So you'll see the points along
the graph.
And
just to show you how this was working,
there was one line that I removed.
So let's copy that again. The one line
I removed was just drop us down to
a single
CPU,
run it again, we get a single point.
And if we view the raw data,
we just have one point per window.
Okay.
So
how many tables? Well, you can read the
explanation for that there if you wish.
What's important here is that this
combination
of how to add one to the group
there. Yeah. I do talk about the group
here.
So you can read that. Just in the
interest of time, there's only a few minutes
left. But
this is a very common operation to do
a window aggregation
and then flatten or regroup, changes the group
key.
It's one of the most common time series
queries that you're gonna do against your data.
So I show that there's a helper called
aggregate window to do this all for you.
So if we come over here,
we can just see,
I'll just remove this measurement CPU,
build usage user, window one minute, calculate mean,
click the go button,
and there we go. And we'll
remove, we'll use our time range start so
we can get the full graph.
And now we're starting to get nice graphs
that show the CPU load
over time on this machine at one minute
intervals.
If we wanna flatten this out a bit,
we'd probably do it at five.
Of course, I'm gonna need more data points,
so let's do this.
And now that is what we expect, right?
As you work with Grafana and InfluxDB,
Prometheus, all of these tools,
We just wanna be able to understand fluctuations
and values over time, our windows that we
decide the resolution that is important to us
so that we can have a graph that
represents
normal
so that we can alert on not normal.
And that is fundamental to what we're doing
today.
So aggregate windows,
you can do it manually. We have a
window, we have an aggregate function, we have
another group,
or just use their function. In fact, if
you pull up the InfluxDB docs,
the implementation of aggregate window is the window
function group,
like so.
So there are exercises here. I was hoping
I would have time to do them today,
but
I won't. What I will do is I
will schedule or I will record myself doing
each of these exercises and get that uploaded
as a tutorial session and the course.
Please go in and check out exercises two
in your own time. Use the Discord to
ask for help. Use the comments to ask
for help. I'm here.
I wanna be able to help you.
So that is workshop one, an introduction to
Flux. I hope you found that useful. Let
me know how you got on. I'll speak
to you all soon. Have a wonderful day.
Bye.